on va voir quelque chose au sujet de la
yougoslavie un sujet et vous me direz si
c'est de la foi aussi c'est le vin taxes
sur les hauteurs de longwy on peut
passer distraitement devant la façade du
café le gamin de paris le siège du club
de rugby local sans se douter un seul
instant que derrière le comptoir cette
petite dame sympathique qui sert les
clients est la soeur aînée de stipe
mesic le nouveau président de la
république yougoslave alors un président
c'est mon frère et puis c'est quand même
quelque chose de précis d'intérêt public
je pensais quand même qui sera arrivé et
lui à 57 ans premier président non
communistes de la yougoslavie
ce juriste de formation à la difficile
tâche de régler au plus vite le conflit
armés meurtriers entre serbes et croates
doit tout d'abord faire appliquer le
cessez le feu qui pourrait constituer un
premier pas vers un futur plan de paix
un pacifiste et non violente pour lui je
crois qu il vaut mieux toujours réglé
une solution pacifique prend mais savait
que je m'inquiétais un été peu
alors il m'a dit ne t'inquiète pas ça va
durer quelques temps et puis je pense
que tout va s'arranger
arrivé en france en 1937 à l'âge de 4
ans marinette avec une grande partie de
sa vie séparé de son frère mais depuis
quelques années ils se téléphonent
régulièrement
on dit même que parfois ils se rendent
visite je suis un habitué de café
l'occasion de voir sur le président son
frère la dernière fois que le président
yougoslave est venue alors oui c'était
en 86 pour le mariage de sa nièce
florence aujourd'hui marine est à se
faire que sa charge suprême le conduira
à nouveau en france
mais cette fois en visite officielle
alors il ne manquera pas de venir
embrasser au gamin de paris son dernier
petit neveu un gamin de l'ongle
enfin savoir quelques jours en fait
j'étais prête
voilà alors la soeur du président
yougoslave tient tel un bistrot à longwy
s de l'info s de l'intox
jacques vergès à l'oreille ben on attend
la vie c'est de l'info c'est de l'intox
c'est un top se complètent ouais faut
encore une invention de philibert à
tétouan moi je pense que c'est une intox
parce que tracks affaires de voir sa
nièce on n'y pense pas que ça à faire si
oui et surtout en ce moment pour dire on
a exactement dont je pense que c'est de
l'intox avant et vous jacques vous
m'aviez dit que c'était de l'intox aussi
à mon avis oui bon ayant c'est une bonne
soirée philippe alors c'est lui boehner
s'est mieux gologo nos biens écoute la
semaine dernière écouter la semaine
dernière on n'était pas sûr d'être bon
parce que les candidats trouver tout
cette semaine grâce à georges et madonna
on est sûr d'être bon parce que c'est de
là
tina se dit s'il vous plaît est ce que
fait quelque chose à ajouter mon petit
non j'ai juste un petit bonjour a
adressé à marinette on est à côté d'elle
et on pense à elle dans toute l'équipe
de double jeu aussi paradoxal que cela
puisse paraître les cours est sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux